not first of all among the former
habitants of relief not about veterans
but mainly about you few examples just
when the Ukrainian state was established
on the next year there increase of the
candidates applying to attend Ukrainian
studies at Warsaw University where the
four times more students came to study
Ukrainian studies today on a few percent
of the students in Ukrainian studies has
Ukrainian background mainly they are
young pause a week ago or the group of
students match US ambassador and he
asked them why they chose Ukrainian
studies as as a subject the answer was
because it's a field of study with
significant opportunities we more and
more often can match young balls people
in the age of 20 25 speaking perfectly
Ukrainian some of them are developing
the homepages the links are with the
partners and finally the research
service on the third sector in Poland
showed that the highest numbers of
projects of activities are international
activities of Polish and Jos is a link
to UK there is a big financial support
of the German and polish state to polish
German relations but polish grain
relations more than two times more and
jobs involved in such partnership
when we are thinking about the history
about the 15 years of cooperation from
the term of 80s and 90s the first and
GOC too involved the first institution
to involve on the polar side with those
who started in underground who started
as opposition we have to remember about
character about polish Czech Slovak
solidarity foundation has sinky
committee promised society but at the
same moment the new ng offices were
established we can say about Institute
for democracy in Eastern Europe
education for democracy foundation trnn
and and several others the first
contacts were mainly above the past
about building bridges about linking
partners it was for Poland time were we
had to deal with our history and we had
to rebuild the relationships with
national minorities which were under
communism not recognized as existed in
the middle of 90s we have the new
situation the group of leading NGOs is
about 10 ng offices which are
involved in the activities abroad of
Poland first of all in Ukraine and they
became to open the paths they they start
to bring other partners we should say
about form of Central in Eastern Europe
operating in the framework of stefan
batory foundation in statistics studies
center for social economic research case
helsinki foundation for human rights and
those whom i mentioned before and from
1999 we have absolutely new situation at
this moment more than 100 polish
non-governmental organization became
started to work permanently are in the
partnership with Ukrainian and josie's
and what became interesting to have
Ukrainian partners to have partners from
the former Soviet bloc